[Applaudissements]
projetons nous ensemble dans le futur un
futur peut-être pas si lointain
saurions-nous ensemble plongé dans ses
réflexions sur ce thème cuit sans peur
faict imperfections peut-être pas
peut-être que la moitié de nos places
seraient vides
peut-être que beaucoup d'entre nous
n'existerions plus car notre adn 7
cette incroyable double hélice au coeur
de chacune de nos cellules
notre adn avec ses inévitables
imperfections ne nous aurait peut-être
pas accordé le droit de poursuivre notre
vie au delà de l'éprouvette et du tri
nos places seraient vides et peut-être
que ceux qui auraient eu la chance de ne
pas être mis au tapis par ce tamis
génétique
peut-être cela ne serait-il pas tout à
fait eux mêmes et on aura essayé de les
modifier génétiquement pour leur donner
un un qi qui explose tous les scores ou
pour en faire des génies en maths ou
peut-être pour faire qu'ils ne
ressentent pas la peur
laissez moi vous parler du toboggan sur
lequel glisse déjà l'humanité dans sa
folle quête de perfection génétique
vous le savez sûrement on est capable
d'analyser l'adn le séquencée au moins
pour pour ce qu'on en sait et on peut
aussi faire ça sur les embryons pour
cela on les conçoit une vie trop et puis
on prélève une ou deux cellules et puis
on les analysons les séquences et on les
sélectionne déjà d'abord cela se
justifie pour éviter des maladies très
graves
et puis ensuite des pathologies un peu
moins grave
d'abord on ne recherche qu'un seul
critère et puis ensuite un large
éventail et puis des traits de caractère
est d'abord on le réserve aux familles à
risque et puis ensuite petit à petit on
l'étend à tous les embryons et puis à
toute la population pour pour peut-être
en arriver un jour à donner ou retirer
un permis de faire
ces baby sous la couette je voudrais
vous parler d'une de mes amies une
collègue avec qui je travaillais avant
dans l'industrie elle a eu un cancer du
sein l'année de ses 50 ans ce cancer
avait un petit quelque chose des ready
terre parce qu'un gène un morceau de son
adn l'avez sûrement malheureusement
prédisposé à déclencher cette maladie
avec notre merveilleuse médecine avec
des des soignants des vhu et puis aussi
avec son son mental d'acier elle la
traversée elle a survécu et des années
après mais longtemps après j'ai appris
que ce gène en question
il peut désormais justifier l'accès à
ces techniques pour concevoir et
sélectionner et rejeter les embryons
fille qui en sont porteurs alors j'ai
repensé à elle la place de cet ami
aujourd'hui seraient vides parce que les
biotechnologies aurait décidé par avance
et à sa place que sa vie ne valait pas
la peine d'être vécue ce savoir porteur
d'une prédisposition génétique ça peut
être source vraiment d'un progrès
immenses dans la mesure où ça peut
permettre une surveillance ajuster une
médecine même personnaliser en fait la
connaissance génétique
c'est une bonne nouvelle on peut s'en
émerveiller s'en réjouir mais tout
dépend de ce qu'on en fait parce que ici
ce tri est ce que c'est une victoire
contre la maladie
ou est ce que c'est une victoire de la
sélection aux états unis des sociétés
proposent ces techniques est pour
quelques milliers de dollars
on sélectionne déjà les embryons selon
la couleur des yeux on sélectionne déjà
les embryons selon leur sexe et vous
voyez que cette discrimination ou garçon
fille dont on entend tellement parler
elle devient technologique et elle
s'invite au début de notre vie au stade
de quelques cellules en angleterre les
critères pour avoir recours à ces
techniques qui sont sur une liste
une liste disponible sur internet
une liste qui s'allonge régulièrement et
au milieu maladie très grave on trouve
les prédispositions et même le gène du
strabisme plus étonnant peut-être encore
des couples certains couples qui sont
atteints de surdité choisissent d'avoir
recours à ces techniques pour concevoir
sélectionnés et garder leurs embryons
porteurs de surdité et il rejette les
normaux ceux qui entendraient pourquoi
parce que en fait ils veulent
transmettre leur handicap en héritage
parce que pour eux l'enfant parfait
ils partagent leurs moyens de
communication c'est leur vision de la
perfection des scientifiques travaillent
sérieusement aussi sur le lien entre eux
quotient intellectuel et génétique avec
pour objectif de développer des
algorithmes ou des intelligences
artificielles pour améliorer la la
sélection voire même l'amélioration
elle-même des embryons en lien avec
cette cette note se cuit mais jusqu'où
ira cette soumission de la vie aux
biotechnologies je voudrais qu'on
réfléchisse ensemble est-ce que cette
mentalité qui se met en place
elle ne nous cantonne pas à penser
l'humain de demain au travers d'une
qualité biologique de départ ou au
travers d'une prétendue perfection cette
quête de perfection est une illusion
elle est et elle sera la source
d'immense des illusions je le crains
parce que au motif d'épargné certaine
souffrance pourrait bien au contraire en
engendrer de nouvelles et si à mesure
que la technique court derrière cette
illusion de vouloir perfectionner
l'espèce humaine
derrière cette tentation de vouloir
rendre autrui meilleur est ce que
pendant ce temps là ce ne serait pas
nous-mêmes et notre société que nous
rendions - meyer s que ces progrès
technologiques sont tous des progrès
humain
vous connaissez tous je pense cette
expression quand quand on veut parler de
quelqu'un qu'on connaît un prof ou un
proche ou un collègue ou quelqu'un qu'on
rencontre régulièrement quelqu'un que
nous apprécions parce que c'est
quelqu'un quelqu'un qui fait du bien
quelqu'un qui nous fait du bien et alors
pour parler de lui ou bien de l nous
disons que c'est quelqu'un de très
humain
ça m'a toujours amusé cette expression
parce que en fait il est pas plus humain
que vous que moi on est tous des humains
mais je crois qu'en fait ce qu'on met
derrière cette expression c'est que ce
ne sont pas des critères de force ou de
cuillé ou de performance ou de puissance
ou même d'apparence je crois que ce que
nous mettons derrière cette expression
c'est que c'est quelqu'un de bon au sens
de bonté et ça c'est pas génétique
j'aime à penser que la bonté sauvera le
monde
la génétique la molécule d'adé n est
vraiment une molécule incroyable qu'on
n'a pas fini d'explorer d'ailleurs plus
la science avance plus nous savons que
nous ne savons pas grand chose
finalement
depuis que je vous parle des cellules de
votre corps du mien aussi sont mortes et
d'autres sont nés en fait on se
renouvelle en permanence d'ailleurs je
sais pas si vous savez mais on sait déjà
tous entièrement renouvelé plusieurs
fois depuis que nous existons mais si
nous restons les mêmes malgré ce
permanent renouvellement c'est grâce à
un mystérieux principes de vie qui nous
anime qui nous animera jusqu'à notre
mort et qui nous anime depuis que nous
n'avons été qu'une seule et unique
première cellule depuis notre création
ou plutôt depuis notre conception depuis
que c'est inventé combiné pour la
première fois notre adn
l'adn c'est vraiment une
une pièce maîtresse
qui permet à la vie de se déployer
l'adn compte beaucoup pour construire
qui on est déjà ils portent notre
hérédité peut-être savez-vous que
chacune des cellules qui nous composent
chacune des milliards de cellules qui
nous composent chacune d'elles possède
une partition de l'adn de deux mètres de
long 2 mètres de long mais cette
partition elle n'est pas totalement
figée au contraire notre vie se charge
d'y ajouter des des bémols des dièses
dans une dans une mystérieuse
interprétation de l'épigénétique en fait
notre partition de l'adn elle résonne
avec avec le monde qui nous entoure avec
notre petit monde avec nos habitudes
avec nos modes de vie avec aussi les
événements qui nous arrive avec nos
peines avec nous avec nos joies avec ce
qu'on mange ce qu'on respire
et puisqu'on voit aussi les quatre
lettres de notre adn n'écrivent pas
toute notre vie notre sort notre
histoire ne sont pas scellées dans nos
gènes la génétique et et je crois
qu'elle restera plein de mystères parce
que l'homme est un mystère
malheureusement il ya des fautes de
frappe dans notre adn
on peut même dire que nous sommes tous
génétiquement un parfait et certains le
savent parce que parce que cela se voit
ou parce que cela se vit malheur mystère
injustice scandales même ça fait mal ça
fait du mal en fait 7,1 mal mais ce qui
est un mal c'est la maladie pas le
malade dans ces situations l'entr'aide
la solidarité s'avère parfois
fondamentale même vital en fait la
vulnérabilité
elle permet la solidarité
la vulnérabilité c'est je crois ce qui
fait notre commune humanité
c'est ce qui nous relie c'est ce qui
nous donne un sort commun
c'est peut-être même le seul point
commun entre tous les êtres humains
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas alors voir
cette vulnérabilité comme étant la
pierre d'angle des relations humaines à
travers elle je pense peut naître la
fraternité un ciment si fragile dont nos
sociétés individualistes et blessés
tellement besoin
nos limites mais tout comme les
innombrables re dont et talent que nous
possédons tous nos limites construisent
aussi qui on est et je crois que que nos
fragilités que les fragilités de ceux
que nous aimons de ceux que nous
rencontrons elles deviennent parfois le
lieu d'une d'une intense créativité même
de de pulsion de vie parfois c'est ce
qui déclenché des vocations ou c'est ce
qui donne sens à une mission c'est aussi
parfois ce qui nous donne la force de
nous surpasser
parce que dans l'épreuve on peut faire
ses preuves
c'est ce qui nous donne l'envié de
prendre soin les uns des autres et chez
certains nous le voyons ça déclenche
même là la fougue l'énergie le le grain
de folie l'espoir peut-être de vouloir
changer le monde pour rendre le monde
meilleur
je ne crois pas qu'il faille concevoir
un monde des meilleurs parce que vouloir
tout maîtriser
est ce que ce n'est pas quelque part
tout mépriser pour qu'une société
progresse vers faire plus de justice
vers plus de solidarité
est-ce qu'elle ne doit pas commencer par
nous recevoir pour qui on est n a été
pour qui on est le sts qu'elle ne doit
pas s'organiser et puis tout mettre en
place pour eux pour accueillir mais
aussi pour accompagner l'imprévisible et
la fragilité qui de toute façon ne
manque jamais d'arriver
je crois que le monde se construit avec
des forts et avec des fragiles combien
de combien de cabosser combien de tordu
de deux pauvres ou aussi de personnes
dont la vie a été fauchée bien trop tôt
combien ont marqué de leur empreinte
l'histoire du monde du plus grand génie
aux plus grands artistes et je suis sûr
que des visages vous viennent au coeur
est et à l'esprit parce que leur mémoire
verse toutes les époques de ses plus
grands là au plus petit discret anonyme
inconnue combien d'un parfait ont fait
progresser notre humanité
heureux les fêlés parce qu'il passait la
lumière heureusement que personne n'est
venu couper leur destin génétique le
monde se construit avec des forts et
avec des faibles l'un pouvant devenir
l'autre à tout instant mais l'un est en
l'autre à tout moment aussi quand je
suis faible
c'est alors que je suis fort chacun de
nous est un parfait mais chacun de nous
est le seul à pouvoir prendre la place
qui nous attend et je crois que c'est ça
qui fait de chacun de nous d'être une
irremplaçable parfaite imperfections je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]